president Trump fights back against the
Democrats impeachment William Bar goes
after the Obama FBI and Miriam Webster
redefines the word they I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show this show
is sponsored by expressvpn stop putting
your online data at risk get protected
and expressvpn calm slash Ben okay so
we're gonna get to all the impeachment
related news of the day but there are a
couple of stories then we need to
comment on right at the top here because
the media malfeasance here is utterly
stunning utterly stunning and the
malfeasance of many on the Left is
utterly stunning the stories that I'm
talking about their dual stories and
they're sort of connected by the
coverage of anti-semitism in the United
States story number one is that there
was an anti-semitic terror attack in
Jersey City yesterday it was pretty
clear from the very beginning and when
somebody drives to a kosher supermarket
in Jersey seemed like the only kosher
supermarket in the area and then
proceeded to have a shootout with police
probably they were targeting the kosher
supermarket because it's a really random
location right why aren't they just
walking into the local supermarket
they're there tons of supermarkets in
Jersey said you won't have a shootout
with the cops presumably you could go
anywhere as a Jew your first suspicion
if somebody holds up in a synagogue and
starts shooting at the cops or somebody
holds up in a Jewish supermarket in a
kosher supermarket is that it's a terror
attack and we saw the exact same thing
happen in France a few years back after
the Charlie Hebdo massacre I believe it
was when the suspect ended up driving
over to a kosher supermarket and holing
up there and then Barack Obama
idiotically suggested that these these
shooters had randomly holed up at a
kosher supermarket okay it's very very
unlikely on the list of circumstances it
is very unlikely that in a vast shootout
with police you just randomly end up
with the only kosher supermarket in
Jersey City so as it turns out it was
not random it turns out that the
shooters in this particular case holed
up at a kosher supermarket and proceeded
to shoot at the cops six people are dead
including the two shooters there is
apparently a police officer a 15 year
veteran of the florist with five
children who was shot to death by these
pieces of human debris as well as three
people inside the store
all three were Jews and and died in the
store according to NBC News we are now
finding out who these suspects are there
was no coverage of it for nearly 24
hours
everybody sort of tried to figure out
who the suspects were and it turns out
that one of the two suspects had a
social media page containing anti Jewish
writings chakra shocker officials and
sources said on Wednesday for law
enforcement sources familiar with the
case told NBC New York the suspects were
apparently a man and a woman I'm not
going to mention their name I don't
mention the names of shooters or mass
killers on my program but the suspects
were apparently one-time followers of
the black Hebrew Israelite men and the
male suspect there's a male suspect and
a female suspect apparently they were
black which is only relevant insofar as
the media will only cover this stuff or
have national conversations on
anti-semitism if the shooters happen to
be white supremacist if the shooters
happen to be white supremacist or can in
any way be blamed on president Trump
then we'll have a national conversation
about President Trump and about ideology
and we'll have a conversation about the
tenor of our politics if however there's
a radical spike in anti-semitism in say
New York City which there has been in
the past several years Jews in
Williamsburg being beaten on the streets
in huge numbers if that happens then the
media don't cover it that's not me
saying that the New York Times said that
knocked over of last year they said why
haven't we been covering all of the
anti-semitic attacks in Williamsburg in
Brooklyn New York
well the reason is because none of them
are coming from white supremacist we
can't spot a pattern anywhere
well maybe the pattern is the
anti-semitism maybe the pattern doesn't
have to be your preferred mode of
anti-semitism that you can blame on
somebody else
there's a very easy way to tell whether
people care about Jew hatred do they
care about it when the person who is
committing the Jew hatred happens to be
more politically aligned with them than
the opposite okay do you care about
anti-semitic attacks if it happens to be
a white supremacist or do you only care
about anti-semitic attacks if it happens
to be a person on the left or vice versa
if the answer is only one or the other
it means you don't care about
anti-semitism right means that you only
care about the political hey that can be
made from talking about anti-semitism so
it turns out that the male in this case
was a one-time follower of the black
Hebrew Israelite meant for people who
don't know the black Hebrew Israelite
movement it's a nonsensical mishmash of
horrible stereotypical racism and also a
bunch of nonsense garnered from bad
readings of the Bible these are not Jews
they proclaim in their ideology that
they are a Lost Tribe I believe the Lost
Tribe of the Jews
the actual Jews today are not actual
Jews they are fake Jews and surprisingly
it turns out that they don't like Jews
right they don't like Jews very much
shocker shocker inside the van used by
the shooter's was a note with religious
writings according to the three sources
Jersey City Mayor Steven Fulop said at a
news conference on Wednesday morning
security footage from the Tuesday
incident showed the shooters traveling
slowly through the streets in a u-haul
van stopping outside the store armed
with long guns and immediately opening
fire so obviously they were targeting
the location public safety director Jim
Shea said there were multiple other
people on the street there were many
other targets available to them that
they bypassed to attack that place
shocker so it was clearly that was their
target they intended to harm people
inside there Shea emphasized the
shooter's motive is not yet clear and is
under investigation yes I am sure that
they just really really really did not
like the matzo ball soup that they had
obtained from the kosher store three
weeks earlier I can't have been that
they were targeting the kosher
supermarket of course they were
targeting the kosher supermarket of
course they're anti-semites and of
course the black Hebrew Israelite
movement has had serious problems with
anti-semitism for a very very long time
it is rare they're gonna hear me cite
the Southern Poverty Law Center because
the Southern Poverty Law Center is fond
of calling basically everybody who is
right-of-center
a white supremacist but their coverage
of the black Hebrew Israelite movement
is actually true they point out that the
black supremacist wing of the Hebrew
Israelite movement is spreading and its
leaders are growing increasingly
militant this is as of August 2008 and
they talk in about the the growth of the
black Hebrew Israelite men it's a black
nationalist theology dating back to the
19th century its doctrine asserts that
blacks are God's true chosen people
because they not the people known to the
world today as Jews are the real
descendants of the Hebrews of the Bible
they it's it's a bizarre movement it
doesn't have tons of acolytes but
obviously some of its fringe acolytes
are dangerous hey three civilians were
found dead inside the Jersey City store
following what became an hours-long
standoff and shootout between police and
the suspects the suspects were also
found said the only victim identified so
far is a Jersey City police detective
Joseph seals 39 he was killed after
police investigating the murder
approached the two shooting suspects and
one of them opened fire hitting the
officer in the head so here's the reason
this is relevant okay the reason this is
relevant is number one whenever there's
an anti-semitic terror attack it should
be relevant reason number two is because
this will disappear
within 24 hours you will never hear
about it again right you will still hear
about the enzymatic attacks at tree of
life or at the Habad in Poway you won't
hear about this anti-semitic attack and
that is not based on the identity of the
people who are killed or the people who
are attacked it is based solely on the
identity of the people who committed the
attack because we now live in a media
world in which unless you can draw a
narrative that you like from the
particular act of anti-semitism you
don't cover it it again it was pretty
obvious as soon as this happened at a
kosher supermarket what exactly was
going on it was just a question as to
who did it but that doesn't change the
nature of the attack wait until you hear
what builds Blasio that tool bag of
stupid actually tweeted about this it's
actually incredible we'll get to that in
just one moment first let's talk about
your business for just a second if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business the fact is if you want to
run a successful business you have to
know your business inside and out and
the best way to do that is to not have a
bevy of non-aligned computer systems
trying to keep track of your business
instead you should be using NetSuite by
Oracle the business management software
that handles every aspect of your
business in an easy-to-use cloud
platform giving you the visibility and
control you need to grow with NetSuite
you save time money and unneeded
headaches by managing sales finance and
accounting orders in HR instantly
directly from your desktop or phone
that's why NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system it's
hard to manage your business if you're
using again a bevy of different systems
that don't align with one another
instead you have an entire integrated
business system with NetSuite and right
now NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits and
NetSuite comm slash capiro that is
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro to download
your free guide seven key strategies to
grow your profits
NetSuite comm slash up here we'll go
check them out right now NetSuite comm
slash Shapiro and again make your
business better NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro and you get that free guide ok
so Bill DeBlasio this ignorant and
horrific mayor of New York here's what
he tweeted out quote this tragically
confirms that a growing pattern of
violent anti-semitism has now turned
into a crisis for our nation and now
this threat has reached the doorstep of
New York City Oh has it reached the
doorstep has it has it because um there
is like a multiple time spike in
anti-semitic attacks in New York over
past three years everyone knows this
there are FBI statistics to prove it
anti-semitic attacks in New York have
spiked radically under Mayor Bill
DeBlasio but apparently he's only
noticing now that anti-semitism is the
thing oh isn't that nice that Bill de
Blasio is finally catching on how
delightful how delightful demonstrating
once again that it only when it when it
comes to anti-semitism it's only useful
to people of a who don't care about
anti-semitism if it can be blamed on
people on the other side okay now I want
to juxtapose the coverage of this
anti-semitic terror attack by black
Hebrew Israelites in Jersey City with
the coverage of a of an executive order
from President Trump yesterday so
President Trump comes out with an
executive order it's a very simple
executive order I had heard about it a
little bit in advance and the executive
order is basically designed to extend
title six protections on college campus
to Jews so title six protections on
college campuses are basically designed
to protect against discrimination based
on shared ancestry ethnic
characteristics race national origin so
if a school is deemed to not take
seriously racism it could lose its
federal funding so there's a racist
incident that takes place on campus the
school doesn't do a full investigation
the school could lose its federal
funding if there is a if there is a an
attack on not just black Native American
people there's an attack on Latino
people on college campuses if there's
any of that and the school doesn't take
it seriously it could lose its title six
federal funding well going all the way
back to the Obama administration there
was a Department of Education policy
that's that's stated that discrimination
on the basis of quote shared ancestry or
ethnic characteristics actual or
perceived if that's not taken seriously
by the school they could lose federal
funding that's an Obama era policy okay
so I'm reading directly from the
Department of Education website these
regulations will promulgate it as early
as 2010 under the Obama administration
okay so this is not new it's just this
has now become a full on federal policy
from the top of the executive branch
it's not just the Department of
Education guideline and now it's actual
policy but these guidelines were first
drawn up in Senator Harry Reid's office
okay there first thrown up in Senator
Harry Reid's office from there first
looked at by the Obama Department of
Education and here's what they said
title six of the Civil Rights Act
1964 protects students from race color
and national origin discrimination this
prohibition encompasses discrimination
including harassment based on a
student's actual or perceived shared
ancestry or ethnic characteristics or
citizenship or residency in a country
with the dominant religion or distinct
religious identity
the goe explicitly said these laws
protect students who are who are or are
perceived to be members of a religious
group such as Buddhists Christians
Hindus Jews Muslims and Sikhs from
discrimination on any of the basis
described above title six prohibits
discrimination against students of any
religion when the discrimination
involves racial ethnic or ancestral
epithets or slurs how a person or group
looks dresses or speaks if linked to
ethnicity or ancestry potential or
allegedly inherit traits stereotypes
about people who share certain ancestral
or ethnic characteristics okay so the
school violates title six when harassing
conduct on the basis of these things is
sufficiently serious as to limit or deny
a student's ability to participate in or
benefit from an educational program for
example so the school doesn't do
anything to crack down and students feel
discriminated against it's basically
sexual harassment law applied to racial
or ethnic harassment on college campuses
okay so President Trump then promulgates
an executive order and listen to the way
that the New York Times covers this
executive order because it is some of
the worst media coverage I've ever heard
and it prompts some of the stupidest
claims by people who hate Trump that I
have ever heard I mean literally ever
heard and then people make stupid claims
about Trump all the time Trump has
broken a lot of people's brains the fact
that Trump is president has made a lot
of people say dumb things they would
never otherwise say and so according to
the New York Times Trump targets
anti-semitism and Israeli boycotts on
college campuses the president's order
would allow the government's withhold
money from campuses deemed to be biased
but critics see it as an attack on free
speech okay first of all you can make a
libertarian case the title six of the
Civil Rights Act violates First
Amendment prescriptions that really if
people on college campuses decide to say
racist or sexist or or anti-jewish
things anti-semitic things that that
should be allowed because the First
Amendment is not allowed Congress shall
make no law abridging freedom of speech
right that's a libertarian case it's a
case I hear but if title six exists it
should apply to Jews the same way that
it applies to black people or Latino
people or Native Americans or hate or
see
or Hindus obviously so here's what the
New York Times says they say President
Trump plans to sign an executive order
on Wednesday targeting what he sees as
anti-semitism on college campuses by
threatening to withhold federal money
from educational institutions that fail
to combat discrimination three
administration officials said on Tuesday
now this would be a good thing for Jews
on campus I know lots of Jews on campus
I know Jews on campuses like NYU are
routinely discriminated against by
professors and students alike the order
will effectively interpret Judaism as a
race or nationality not just a religion
to prompt a federal law penalizing
colleges and universities deemed to be
shirking their responsibility to foster
an open climate for minority students in
recent years the boycott divestment and
sanctions movement against Israel has
roiled some campuses leaving some Jewish
students feeling unwelcome or attacked
ok let's be frank about this the State
Department definition of anti-semitism
does encompass some anti-israel language
meaning that if you are if you are
claiming that Israel is a racist Nazi
apartheid state that is considered
anti-semitism which it should be because
it is under State Department policy okay
but that does not mean that all
criticism of Israel is now outlawed on
college campuses or something dumb like
that hey if you single out Israel among
all the other states for behavior that
you don't care about from any other
state that is a form of anti-semitism
that has always been a form of
anti-semitism yeah the double standard
is a form of anti-semitism this was
acknowledged by the Obama administration
this is nothing new
Trump was just formalizing something
that was already known which is why this
is a legal executive order but here is
the part two people are going nuts about
that coverage okay so the New York Times
says the order will effectively
interpret Judaism as a race or
nationality and not just a religion
okay so let's be frank about this being
Jewish is all of the above it is all of
the above so I've gotten a lot of flack
personally for saying that I don't care
particularly much about ethnic Judaism
when it comes to whether I take
someone's opinion seriously on Judaism I
don't care what Noam Chomsky has to say
about Judaism he doesn't know anything
about it the fact that he was born
Jewish really has very little to do with
any of his opinions on Judaism right
when when I'm talking about people who
are speaking about the the Jewish
mission or Jewish ideology or Jewish
philosophy I'm going to take more
seriously people who take Jewishness
more seriously but when it comes to
anti-semitism which is what the CEO
was about when it comes to
characterizing Jews obviously choose our
ethnicity obviously Jews our nationality
and Jewish nation hood has been a part
of religious Jewish thought since
literally the Bible right when I talked
about Omni surah L that means the nation
of Israel this is there's nothing new
here okay so the idea that Trump did
something new by labeling Judaism race
nationality and religion in the United
States that's nothing new at all nor is
that meant to take Jews and then put
them in a separate category now as we'll
see people because their brains are
broken and they have lost all I mean
like they've lost all control of their
mental functions have decided that is
anti-semitic for Trump to protect Jews
on college campuses by acknowledging
that anti-semites treat them as a people
despite their religiosity I've been told
by left-wing Jews by the way left-wing
Jews who aren't religious secular Jews
how dare you connect Jewishness with
Judaism how dare you ben shapiro can you
keep saying they you are more jewish if
you actually care about judaism how dare
you I'm just as much of a Jew as you are
right you're just as muffin much of an
ethnic Jew as I am but there's another
element which is religious Judaism so
I've been criticized for for conflating
Jewishness with Jewish with Jewish
religion right I'm not saying that it's
exclusively Jewish religion but yes
Jewish religion plays a part and how
Jewish you are obviously in terms of
your practice or your philosophy or your
ideology but left-wing Jews will say you
know you you have no more basis to speak
about Judaism than I do even though I've
never read the Bible and don't care
about Judaism now they're taking
precisely the opposite tack now they are
saying that if Trump says what they say
right if Trump says right Jewishness is
about more than just your religious
practice they go up anti-semitic now
you're labeling us two people apart and
now you're preparing an answer somatic
attack wait until you hear this
unbelievable idiocy which by the way is
also a complete perversion of the nature
of an executive order designed to
protect Jews on college campuses who are
very much under attack on college
campuses right now okay we'll get to all
of this in just one second Trump broke
people's brains people have lost their
damn minds
I'll get to that in one second first
let's talk about a sad reality
two out of three dudes are going to
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they are
thirty-five and once that hair is gone
the chances of it coming back on mass
for itty much nil that is why you need
to keep
the hair that you have and there is good
news with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and help you keep the hair you have
at half the cost of your local pharmacy
you don't have to go broke to avoid
going bald keeps offers generic versions
of the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there plus some of you may
have tried them before but not for this
price keeps now offers a prescription
shampoo also to keep your scalp healthy
as well prevention is key and keeps
treatment really does work again these
are FDA approved treatments you are just
getting them a lot cheaper through keeps
because you're cutting out the middleman
find out what keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly a hundred thousand men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication keeps treatments start at
just ten bucks a month plus for a
limited time you can get your first
month for free that's a hell of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm slash band to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is ke EPS calm slash pen
keeps calm slash pen okay so every Jew
ever until like apparently this moment
has understood that being a Jew is a few
separate things that are altogether
right it is a religion Judaism is
religion Judaism is also a nationality
in the sense of it's a shared ancestry
if your mother is Jewish under Jewish
law then you are Jewish it is also a
race in the sense that again it is a
shared ancestry right and a and two to
be considered a philosophical Jew you
have to buy into the religion to be
considered an ethnic Jew you do not have
to buy into the religion for purposes of
anti-semites it doesn't matter as long
as you have any sense of Judaism and you
are ethnically Jewish in any way
anti-semites will come after you and
this is what secular Jews have found out
throughout history throughout history
this has been the truth okay so the left
wing comes out in force against Trump's
yo designed to protect Jews calling
Trump the real anti-semite so the same
people who 24 hours from now will be
completely ignoring the black Hebrew
Israelite massacre at this kosher
supermarket they will be that the same
exact people are gonna be ripping on
Trump as an anti-semite for promulgating
an EO that protects Jews on college
campuses you cannot make this bleep up
you cannot make it up okay so you get
Justin Amash who generally I have liked
right Justin Amash the libertarian from
from Michigan he tweets out Jewish
Americans are American
yeah no bleep dude and guess what so are
black Americans they're also protected
by title six of
the Civil Rights Act like if you say
that black people are a race in the
United States that does not mean that
they are a people apart from Americans
like what the hell are you talking about
okay and then you get and then you get
bianna golodryga
right who's a CNN senior analyst and she
tweets out the intent may be admirable
but the defining label is very Soviet
because the Soviets used to put on their
on their passports that if you were
Jewish they would define your
nationality not a Soviet but as Jewish
okay but that's not what Trump is doing
here what the hell are you talking about
he's acknowledging that Judaism that
being a Jew is not just being a
religious Jew but if you are a secular
Jew if you are an ethnic Jew that you
are also counted as Jew for purposes of
protection under title 6 of the Civil
Rights Act
you're not saying you're up people apart
to be deported or some such crap I mean
what the hell like what we're now going
to pretend that the Jews are not a
nationality that Jews are not a nation
literally Israel is called um yes or
I'll not the State of Israel the people
of Israel the people who's really been a
thing okay this is crazy
Andrea Pitzer who writes books on the
concentration camps she actually tweeted
out hey you know this whole thing were
an authoritarian personality who's
embraced white supremacist onstaff
decides to designate Jews a separate
population category might have some
ramifications down the line the hell is
wrong with you Jews are so now you've
got secular Jews who are telling me five
seconds ago that I was putting too much
focus on Jewish philosophy and religion
in terms of how I define Jewishness
saying that unless you define it as only
religion you are now a white supremacist
who is a Nazi have you lost your damn
mind are you out of your mind what the
hell are you talking about this is crazy
okay and this was it this was the hot
trending meme on Twitter last night it
was the hot meme on Twitter last night
you have to be so ignorant like read a
damn book you idiots
Zach Beauchamp who I met Iglesias is the
Ralph Wiggum of the Internet over at
voxcom Zach Beauchamp is like his more
ignorant younger brother he tweeted out
the leader of a heavily Christian party
using a nonsensical definition of
Judaism to justify a policy that would
be disproportionately used to silence
speech from young Muslims it's too much
are you a crazy person are you
nonsensical definition of Judaism again
that's
always been the definition of Judaism
what in the hell are you talking about
he's Shaun Thor or said we live in an
age where Jews who support BDS are
anti-semites and white nationalists who
back Israel are not so now Trump isn't
is an anti-semite because he apparently
once used to be protected on college
campuses but Jews who support BDS are
not anti-semites because they are ethnic
Jews and therefore cannot be
anti-semitic okay so you can't have it
both ways either the ethnic Judaism is
actually a thing or it's not a thing you
can't this is utterly nonsensical people
hit their heads or they're just damn
liars which is really what this is about
hey Abba Eban who is the former foreign
minister of Israel one of the great
voices in in Jewish history he was asked
about Judaism at one point by Mike
Wallace he's headed to religion it's a
people hood it's a civilization it's a
faith it's a memory it's a world of
thought and spirit and action and it
cannot be restrictive ly defined this is
so insane Aaron Biba another one of
these journalists she suggested that
this was the predicate for the Nuremberg
Laws so you are now denying secular Jews
are now apparently denying they are Jews
in order to own own Trump well done
everyone well done everyone by the way
now you look at the executive order and
what is the executive order do it codify
the exact same definitions used by the
Obama Department of Education the exact
same definitions exactly exact same ones
and points out that if you discriminate
against Jews on campus that's a bad
thing
and they should lose your federal
funding for this Trump is being labeled
an anti-semite and also the anti-semites
don't exist in New York according to
Mayor Bill DeBlasio because they're not
white supremacist yeah me thinks that
the left does not take anti-semitism
very seriously I mean things that the
same left that Cheers Ilhan Oh Martin
receded to leave open anti-semites Jew
haters all the same left that that Pat's
Jeremy Corbyn a Jew hater on the head by
drip by the way jeremy corbyn's party
could theoretically be in power by this
time tomorrow Jeremy Corbyn is so
anti-semitic that the chief rabbi of
Israel condemned the Labour Party 85% of
Jews will vote against labor even though
Jews tend to vote liberal in in Great
Britain anti-semitism is on the rise but
the left doesn't care about that they
literally do not care about it so long
as it comes from the left it's only a
tool to be wielded against people they
disagree with politically it will get
some more of this in just one second
plus well gets all the impeachment
related stuff and everything for
I've needed coffee this month I will be
honest with you there's been a lot of
news and also my kids have been waking
me up and inordinately early hours that
means I need my coffee which coffee do I
use you know which coffee I use black
rifle coffee all month long black rifle
coffee is releasing awesome product
bundles by the way the people run black
rifle coffee
they are awesome dudes military guys
they give some of their money to
military causes there they're just there
they're spectacular guys I mean I know
them I like them and their coffee
happens to be unbelievably good right
now black rifle coffee is releasing
autumn product awesome product bundles
it's a one-stop shop for everyone on
your list I mean it is just the coffee
by the way again again it is fantastic
they have a special limited edition
holiday roast that is excellent their
coffee is not for the weak-minded I mean
this is strong stuff and it is good
stuff it tastes really good I'm sort of
I'm a little bit of a coffee aficionado
I can tell you that black rifle coffee
is excellent stuff when you drink black
rifle coffee you're also supporting a
company that serves coffee and culture
to those who truly love America this
holiday season choose America's coffee
choose black rifle coffee company visit
black rifle coffee calm slash Ben to get
20% off your first purchase that's black
rifle coffee calm slash ban and again
you are going to be helping people who
actually share your viewpoints on the
United States these are not weak-minded
people who are gonna be writing pig on
coffee cups like you might at a
Starbucks know these are these are
people they're pro-military they are
pro-police there they are hardcore dudes
go check out black rifle coffee calm
slash finger your hardcore coffee from
them there they're just great okay so
what exactly is in this executive order
so we were informed by the New York
Times who's going to quash free speech
and also that it was President Trump
doing something totally wild about
Jewish nationality which again is insane
insane okay here's what the executive
order actually says I'm reading it right
now by the authority vested in me as
president of the Khans president by the
Constitution and the laws of the United
States of America is hereby ordered as
follows one my administration is
committed to combating the rise of
anti-semitism and anti-semitic incidents
in the United States and around the
world anti-semitic incidents have
increased since 2013 and students in
particular continue to face anti-semitic
harassment in schools and on University
and college campuses title six of the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 prohibits
discrimination on the basis of race
color and national origin in programs
and activities receiving federal
financial assistance
while title six does not cover
discrimination based on religion
individuals who face discrimination on
the basis of race color or national
origin
do not lose protection under title sex
for also being a member of a group that
shares common religious practices
discrimination against Jews may give
rise to a title sixes 6 violation when
the discrimination is based on an
individual's race color or national
origin and shall be the policy of the
executive branch to enforce title 6
against prohibited forms of
discrimination rooted in anti-semitism
as vigorously as against all other forms
of discrimination prohibited by title 6
and then they talk about how they are
going to define all of this the non
legally binding working definition of
anti-semitism adopted on May 26 2016 by
the international Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance which states anti-semitism is a
certain perception of Jews which may be
expressed as hatred toward Jews
rhetorical and physical manifestations
of anti-semitism are directed toward
Jewish or non-jewish individuals and/or
their property toward Jewish community
institutions and religious facilities
and the contemporary examples of
anti-semitism identified by the
international Holocaust Remembrance
Association to the extent those examples
are useful agencies shall not diminish
or infringe upon any rights protected
under federal law or the First Amendment
so this isn't even going to crack down
on anti-israel speech it is specifically
designed to go after anti-semitic
conduct on college campuses again in
line with the Obama Department of
Education there's not even mention of
Israel anywhere in the EEO nowhere and
this drove people off the edge because
people have lost their damn minds and
because apparently Trump bad Trump
Badman Orange bad very bad Trump bad man
orange just just utter utter crazy
town's utter crazy towns okay now
meanwhile the impeachment effort moves
forward if you think that Trump's
arrangements and remain a thing the
entire first half this show has been
about Trump derangement syndrome okay
now Trump derangement syndrome in
practice so the impeachment is moving
forward despite the fact that Democrats
don't actually have grounds for the
impeachment Doug Collins of Georgia he
said yesterday and he is correct that
the grounds for impeachment are not only
weak they're pretty pretty much
undefined here is Doug Collins pointing
out that the abuse of power charge is
about as big as it gets
abuse of power is the most ambiguous
vague reference to an impeachment that
could ever have you can make it anything
you own you don't
like the president got up in war red tie
that's abuse of power you don't like his
Eric's wah-wah Oh former presidential
candidate wall well said you don't can
be impeached for removing an ambassador
I don't know what he what planet he's
living on but that's not an impeachable
offense but abuse of power we'll give
you that okay and that is exactly right
by the way even Democrats are
recognizing that these things are
incredibly vague and you're seeing an
argument break out on the left /
impeachment should we have broaden this
out to include the mulher stuff just so
we can kind of throw the kitchen sink in
there should we have been more specific
should we have waited for more
information like the Democrats are in
disarray over what exactly this
impeachment means so you have
representative Stephen Lynch pointing
out on CNN yeah this is this is pretty
nebulous and fuzzy I do think you need
to be very specific about what you're
charging the president with and I think
that abuse of power is you know it is a
little bit fuzzier it's sort of nebulous
so you know I think there were probably
elements of you know a conspiracy to
commit bribery that were clearly you
know articulated during the during the
depositions okay so he's saying we
should have gone with bribery the
problem is they didn't have the elements
of bribery so they couldn't go with
bribery on this basis Mitch McConnell in
the Senate he's saying listen there are
not 67 votes here there aren't 50 votes
here here's Mitch McConnell saying this
ain't going nowhere I would be totally
surprised if there were 67 senators to
remove the president that remains my
view however we are obligated under the
Constitution to turn to it when it comes
over and we will yeah on this basis a
small group of Democrats in the house
are recognizing that this is a loser the
polls are turning against impeachment
people don't think there's much there
there and they certainly don't think
that this is worthy of impeachment as a
general rule like the people who hate
Trump wantem impeach but that's just
because they don't want him to be
president not because they actually
believe that this amounts to an
impeachable offense which is why
Democrats in swing districts are
actually militating against impeachment
and in favor of censure which would have
been the Democrats strongest move here
right they've had to put the Republicans
on record either backing Trump's play or
not backing trumps play but without any
real ramifications for Trump other than
sort of general political disapproval
now because they've reached for
impeachment on this thing they're not
gonna get anything from
Republicans and even swing Democrats are
a little bit uneasy about this a group
of about ten lawmakers according to
Politico including representatives Josh
got heimer of New Jersey Kurt Schrader
of Oregon Anthony Brindisi of New York
and ben mcadams of Utah they say yeah
central would've been a better player
Schrader said I think it's certainly
appropriate and might be a little more
bipartisan who knows he said time is
slipping by but apparently the the
moderate Democrats are not going to get
what they want instead Nancy Pelosi has
already ruled out censure so they're
gonna go for broke even though they
don't actually have the goods here ok in
just a second we're gonna get to
president Trump's reaction to all of
this he was rallying in Pennsylvania
last night and the man has brass ones
who we'll talk about in just one second
first let us talk about how you manage
your family online the fact is that if
you have kids you do have to figure out
how much screen time you want to give
them so the rules for the pediatrician
suggest no screen time until they are
aged 2 but then their age - so what
exactly do you do to make sure that your
kids are not on screens all day long
like you write you don't want to be on
the screen all day long but you're an
adult your brain is fully developed your
kids not so much this is why you need
circle circle is the award-winning way
to manage your family's online time
across all connected devices inside and
outside your home with circle parents
can filter what content is allowed set
limits for screen time monitor history
and usage even reward kids for good
behavior
just plug circle Homeplus into your
router download the app and you can keep
track across every connected device from
laptops phones and tablets to smart see
these streaming devices and video game
consoles all from one place you would do
anything for your kids so do something
that is easy and that is going to help
them a lot in life and in just their
day-to-day existence and that is
restricting their screen time making
sure that what they see is the stuff
they should be seeing is that they're
not stumbling into bad stuff on the
internet right now our listeners get a
limited-time offer of 30 bucks off of a
circle home plus when you visit meet
circle comm slash bend and enter code
been at checkout again 30 bucks off when
you visit meet circle comm slash Ben
that's a meet circle comm slash pen and
enter code Ben at checkout that's me-80
circle comm slash Ben meet circle comm
slash Ben and enter code Ben to save $30
okay we're gonna get to president
Trump's reaction to all of the
impeachment related activity momentarily
first we have a perfect gift for you to
give this holiday season it is the gift
of me I mean I'm a great gift every
night I go home I wrap myself up in a
bow and I well
we're not gonna go there in any case the
gift of a daily wire membership can be a
gift that you give to all your best
friends including your friends on the
left because they need education from
now until January 1st
all insider plus gift memberships will
be 25% off this means your loved one
will get all the fantastic perks plus
the majestic leftist cheers tumbler ooh
ha ha and you will receive the savings
head on over to daily wear comm for as
little as 10 bucks a month you get our
articles add free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content and our exclusive
daily wear app which is a pretty awesome
feature if you haven't checked it out
yet if you get that new All Access plan
you will get all of these things plus
the legendary leftist ears tumbler in
our brand new asking me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself and come join the fun
again that is 25% off all insider plus
gift memberships this holiday season
give them a gift they will thank you for
all year long go to daily wire.com slash
gift to get your 25% off again that is
daily wire comm slash gift to get your
25% off do not wait we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the Democrats as you can see are
just in a bit of disarray with regard to
exactly how they should approach this
thing so you got Thomas Friedman saying
you must impeach Trump to save America
Thomas Friedman who's most often seen
basically world traveling at the behest
of particular governments and then right
now and then writing sophomoric drool
pieces about those government so he'll
visit China they'll put him up in a nice
hotel be like China is the wave of the
future then I'll head over to Iran and
they'll put him up in a nice hotel it'll
be like the Iranian people love the
Americans and then he'll head on over to
Saudi Arabia and do the exact same thing
he's Thomas Friedman's terrible in any
case Thomas Friedman has a column today
saying President Trump not only should
be impeached he must be impeached if
America's democracy is to remain intact
why because the facts here are not in
doubt indeed Trump's allies in the media
and Congress have largely given up
disputing them Trump held up
congressionally directed taxpayer
funding to strengthen Ukraine's military
aid against Russia until the new
Ukrainian president agreed to do what
Trump called a favor announced that
Ukraine was investigating Trump's most
likely opponents in the 2020
presidential election Trump apparently
thought that just the announcement would
kill Biden's campaign in its crib well I
mean apparently thought is you making
the assumption that is critical to the
impeachment case Thomas Friedman and
then he suggests that we need
impeachment because we don't have
impeachment then the election of 2020
will be illegitimate the integrity of
our elections would be shattered we
would never again have a legitimate
president according to Thomas Friedman
if Trump is not impeached again this is
setting the narrative for the Democrats
that if Trump wins in 2020 then it's not
legit again I've been saying for the
past week this is dangerous stuff the
Democrats thought this was dangerous
stuff as of 2015 now the Democrats have
refused to accept any election they lose
all elections they lose are stolen from
them and all elections they win are the
will of the people hey but the actual
argument over exactly how broad or
narrow the impeachment should be is a
rich one Jamelle Bouie over at new york
times he has more confidence in the
ability of democrats to come up with
impeachable offenses than the democrats
do he has a piece today called two
articles of impeachment for Trump are
nowhere near enough the house should
take its own sweet time and investigate
many more aspects of the president's
perfidious behavior well don't you think
that if the Democrats thought they were
gonna be able to dig something up they'd
actually be able to do it and they would
do it
the answer isn't the answer's no the
answer is the day they don't actually
think they can do it so they're not
doing it so that is wishful thinking by
Jamelle Bouie and then you have other
Democrats saying this is too narrow and
too vague we don't actually know what
we're doing so it's a bit of chaos on
the Democratic side this has led
President Trump to the belief that he is
inevitable so I'm still amused by the
fact that members of the media are going
crazy over Trump's memory on Twitter the
man is a meme machine on fire he's a
Booma meme machine he's actually Silent
Generation made machine he puts out
these these hilarious memes on his own
Twitter account some of them are
hilarious some of them are off-putting
but he's been doing this since the very
beginning because his Twitter account is
a place of fun and gimmicks so you
remember that the media went nuts went
nuts for a picture that we created a
daily wire that he retweeted of himself
putting a medal on the dog they chased
down all Baghdady in a cave before
al-baghdadi blew himself up and the
media went nuts they fact-checked it
fact-check Trump did not actually put
metal on dog he did not give dog medal
of pawner me well mail the media are
going nuts why because Trump retweeted a
tweet from the Trump war room account
which is a meme of presidents from
snapping his fingers like fan OHS it's
actually a meme of Thanos with Trump's
head on him snapping his fingers and
making the Democrats who were calling
for his impeachment disappear here is
what that sounded like
[Music]
in ever
on the solemn day and I recall that the
first forward business like who cares
right so my favorite my favorite
response to this was Democrats paying
well you know what happened at their
nose he ends up losing at the end yes
this is also a popular online meme it's
been popular since the first part of the
of the latest Avengers movie came out
like come on come on
so CNN's Don Lemon is in high dudgeon
about this are we in junior high are we
ok when you go back to simulating sexual
acts with Kathy Griffin on New Year's
Eve on CNN are we in junior high Don
Lemon it has his buddy cop show with
Chris Cuomo every evening where they say
sophomoric idiocy but apparently Irene
junior yes we're in junior high and
you're part of the group and we all get
it yes the yes we are in the answer is
yes we're in junior high the last time
anybody referenced Frederick Hayek was
30 years ago guys nobody's read a book
yes we are in junior high here's Don
Lemon
what are we in tune your high school
like what the hell what is this like
what what I cannot believe it I'm even
having to report this on the news I
can't believe it
I can't believe I'm not taking a break
with Kathy Griffin simulating sexual
acts on New Year's Eve de to report this
on the news I should be having a very
serious conversation with block of wood
Chris Cuomo right now about the legality
of impeachment not about a Trump suit
how why do I even have to first of all
aren't you the anchor you don't have for
a party you could just ignore it instead
high dudgeon Trump tweeted out a meme no
not me oh come on are we all gonna
protect feign outrage about this Trump
is Trump have you not noticed that for
the past several decades Trump has not
changed and he was a very very young man
since birth perhaps he is now in his
seventh decade on this planet yes yes we
are in junior high and you're part of
the group and just because it listen Don
you're not gonna make that your thing
okay meanwhile president Trump was
giving a rally in Pennsylvania and
honestly he seems like he's in a bit of
a good mood because Trump actually likes
the combat right this is the thing about
Trump he's most comfortable when he has
in these combative situations so here
was Trump last night in Pennsylvania
looking rather jolly because he's in
front of a very large crowd this is his
favorite place to be is in front of a
large crowd of his supporters going at
his enemies here is Trump going after
Joe Biden you ever notice my Biden keep
saying he's in the wrong state like if
he's in Ohio it's great to be in Iowa
tonight
if he's in Pennsylvania it's wonderful
to be in the state of Delaware what is
wrong with this guy what's wrong with it
there's something wrong okay there's
something wrong no he keeps how many
times can you do that again this is
Trump's favorite thing he's gonna
continue all and rolling though the
river swollen keep them doggies trolling
Trump hard President Trump also trolled
the Democrats on impeachment and he's in
a very good mood because the impeachment
is not gonna pass it's not going
anywhere in the Senate the Democrats
have basically emptied their cannon I
mean then what else do they have that
they can throw at Trump other than the
same old same old now does that mean
that Trump is winning right now well
according to national polls no in the
state polls he's still pretty durable
apparently in Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Michigan Wisconsin and Michigan
particularly he's very durable according
to the state polls nationally he's still
trailing every single Democrat according
to the latest polls but he is in a good
mood because the saying it's not gonna
go anywhere it isn't I mean basically
this thing is drawing to its sad
conclusion here is President Trump going
after the Democrats on impeachment any
Democrat that votes for this sham will
be voting to sacrifice the House
Majority their dignity and their career
okay so there is there is president
Trump going after the time again
correctly going after the Democrats on
impeachment he says Democrats are even
embarrassed of this stupid impeachment
now I don't think the Nancy Pelosi has
the capacity for embarrassment frankly I
don't think Trump has the capacity for
embarrassment
I think the era of embarrassment is over
but here's President Trump saying that
if the Democrats had any brains they
would be toast impeachment and then an
hour later she announced that she's
going to do us MCA you know why it's a
huge deal and it plays down the
impeachment because they're embarrassed
by the impeachment and our poll numbers
have gone
the roof because of her stupid okay so
he is correct about this meanwhile his
Attorney General is going after his own
FBI so as we've mentioned earlier this
week there was this Inspector General
report from the DOJ that came out we've
gone through it in a fair bit of detail
on the podcast and the radio show and
that IG report was pretty damning for
the FBI showing systemic errors
throughout the system and it's
interesting so the mainstream media
headline was that the Inspector General
Michael Horowitz had found that there
was no bias inside the FBI with regard
to these cases as I pointed out that was
not actually true it just the only
standard that was being used by Michael
Horowitz was didn't meet the baseline
level of legality meaning that if the
people who were biased could make a
claim that they were doing something
legal was that enough and that was the
standard used so just as proof of this
today
Horowitz testified in front of the in
front of the Senate I believe and he was
asked can you say that it wasn't because
of a political bias the 17 Carter page
FISA errors for example his answer was I
do not know which is true he doesn't
know because the President Trump was
going hard after the FBI last night
saying that the scum at the FBI
destroyed people's lives presumably he
is talking here about George papadopolis
and Carter page right who were dragged
through the mud over what apparently
amounted to nothing here's Trump last
night multiple undercover human spies to
surveil and record people associated
with our campaign look how they've hurt
people they've destroyed the lives of
people that were great people that are
still great people their lives have been
destroyed by scum okay by scum okay well
you know were these people scum or were
they or they just bad at their jobs
whatever the motives it is pretty
obvious that the divide in America is
going to grow a larger William bar the
Attorney General rightly suggests that
the FBI launched this probe into an
actual opposing political campaign on
flimsy evidence so he he made a
statement about the IG report basically
saying we disagree that this
investigation ever should have been
launched the IG was only finding whether
a baseline level a very it actually says
the words Lola
in the IG report a low level of
suspicion is necessary to launch an
investigation and Barr says even that
low level by my lights was not met
he says the FBI launched this thing on
basis of nearly nothing residential
campaigns are frequently in contact with
foreign persons and indeed in most
campaigns there are signs of illegal
foreign money coming in and we don't
automatically assume that the campaigns
are nefarious and traitors and acting in
league with foreign powers there has to
be some basis before we use these very
potent powers in our core First
Amendment activity and here I felt this
was very flimsy okay and then William
Barr also suggested that the Trump
campaign was spied on so last night the
media were saying no Trump Trump claimed
that he was spied on by the FBI
that's nonsense he wasn't spied on
here's Barr saying no when when you send
confidential human sources to infiltrate
a candidate's campaign and when you
wiretap members of his foreign policy
aid team in an attempt to get him that
kind of his spying is it not clearly spy
depart I mean that's what electronic
surveillance is I think wiring people up
to go in and talk to people and make
recordings of their conversations is
spying I think going through people's
emails which they did as a result of the
FISA warrant they went through
everything you know from from pages life
it wasn't in the campaign at the point
where nobody got the survey yes but his
emails were go back okay well Lindsey
Graham just asked Michael Horowitz in
testimony whether this was spying he
said let's put it this way if you don't
have a legal foundation to surveil
somebody and keep doing it is that bad
and Horowitz hid absolutely and Graham
said is that spying and horid said it's
illegal surveillance yeah that's fine
so we're supposed to believe that the IG
report rejected Trump it didn't it
rejected the activities of the FBI under
Barack Obama now how high up that goes
is still an open question whether this
whole thing was launched under false
auspices in order to get Trump Barr has
sort of implied that it was and it's not
just Barr implying that it is John ziram
who is the DEA who's doing his own
investigation here now that is still up
in the air here is Barr saying that the
greatest threat to American democracy
was not anything Trump was doing in 2016
it was the military
militarization of law enforcement
against Trump's campaign in 2016 I think
probably from a civil liberty standpoint
the greatest danger to our free system
is that the incumbent government used
the apparatus of the state principally
the law enforcement agencies and the
intelligence agencies both to spy on
political opponents but also to use them
in a way that could affect the outcome
of the election as far as I'm aware this
is the first time in history that this
has been done to a presidential campaign
okay so Barr presumably will bring out
additional evidence of this along with
Jon ziram in the coming weeks we will
keep an eye on that meanwhile it's
nearing the end of the year and so we
get all of these awards given to various
political figures Time magazine gave its
Person of the Year two grand a Sundberg
no shock there Gweneth on berg has been
held up by the media as an example of
true activism I believe Time magazine a
couple of years ago made the Parkland
kids there are people of the year if I'm
not mistaken so this is not anything
shocking it's also troller II from time
trying to draw fire because they
understand some people on the right will
then attack right a Sundberg and then
they can use that as an excuse to say
that people on the right are intolerance
of children or whatever it is listen
greta thon berg is doing what is right
according to her own lights I think that
she is wrong about a lot of this if I
don't think that what she's doing is
particularly useful I don't think that
draw driving ire about a problem that
has no clear and obvious solution is
particularly useful but that's what Time
magazine does the other one that is
going to draw not nearly as much
attention but it's actually kind of more
important for the for the country and
the world moving forward Merriam West
Webster's Collegiate Dictionary has now
named the word they it's word of the
year now you're saying yourself why is
the word VAE a word of the year isn't
that just a word that we use all the
time hobbits the non-binary pronoun it's
using VAE as a singular that's the word
of the year the definition of a as a
non-binary pronoun was added to three
other separate definitions of the word
in September apparently merriam-webster
said that the word of the year winner
was determined by data key moments cited
by the June by the dictionary publisher
where searches spikes were January's
Paris fashion week featuring non-binary
model Oslo grace US Congresswoman
Pramila
Pramila jeyapaul's April statement about
her child being gender non-conforming
and June's pride celebrations
Emily Brewster who is the
your editor at merriam-webster said
pronouns are among the languages most
commonly used words and like other
common words they tend to have been
mostly ignored by dictionary users but
over the past year or so as people have
increasingly encountered the non-binary
use we've inserted we've seen searches
for they grow dramatically yes because
everyone was searching to see if
everyone had lost our collective mind
and until merriam-webster changed the
dictionary to reflect a horrible
grammatical usage the answer was no so
we have now changed the dictionary to
meet the stupidity of an ideology that
suggests that you can identify as
multiple genders at once or no gender at
all
all of this is just sheer nonsense but
good to know that the authoritative
institutions in our society are bowing
before okay time for a thing that I hate
will do some things I hate no things I
like today just things I hate okay so
good news at the Lakers game a few
nights ago there's a singer named Liz oh
well I've really not been familiar with
and she was wearing like I don't even
know where you get this particular
outfit and where is this outfit
available because it seems like not a
great outfit to be honest with you she
was wearing what appeared to be
addressed that covered her front then
she turned around when she saw she was
on camera and it turns out that she was
wearing a thong and she started shaking
her rather ample rear which is not
listen you know beautiful is in many
sizes but she begins shaking her her
groove thing while wearing a thong in
the face of the camera to be put up on
the Billboard so she basically does a
stripper act and she's twerking on the
Billboard if you can't see this here she
is dancing and um and then suddenly you
have her twerking doing a fully
sexualized twerk in a thong at the
Lakers game and people laughing and
cheering oh the hysterical joy of all of
this now if you point out that you
probably should not like you wouldn't
have strippers in a game like strippers
in a game actually twerking on the dance
floor would be a bad way right there are
lots of kids in the crowd it's not
appropriate for children the fact that
this is considered good behavior is
beyond me or this is empowering I'm
confused why it's empowering more than
just shameless right shame seems like a
like guilt guilt seems like a perfectly
fine thing if you're doing something
that affects children like if you if you
get naked in front of children at a
Lakers game that doesn't seem empowering
as much as it just seems like you being
incredibly self-absorbed and not
thinking about anybody whose eyeballs
are on the screen but in any case this
was seen as a sign of body positivity
specifically because she is ample right
because she is not a skinny woman
because she is not in shape human being
this is now seen as empowering because
she's comfortable in her own body well
listen I'm glad for her that she feels
secure in her own body she's made a lot
of money off of off of her talents I
don't know her talents because I'm not
familiar with her work but the fact that
this is now seen as a form of
empowerment let's put it this way if
you're an overweight person and you're
required lizzo taking off her the back
of her dress and shaking her rather
large but in a thong in order for you to
feel better about yourself I would
suggest that you surround yourself with
family and friends who care about you
because no no okay other things that I
hate today so Megan Rapinoe was given
the Sports Illustrated Person of the
Year or athlete of the Year not a shock
she had a great Women's World Cup also
she happens to be a political figure in
Sports Illustrated has become
effectively speaking Time magazine with
basketballs and you know just like ESPN
has become MSNBC with footballs so
Sports Illustrated gives the the sports
Person of the Year to Megan Rapinoe
deserves on the sports level not really
deserved on the political level and they
get exactly what they deserve
Megan Rapinoe then rips into Sports
Illustrated which should have put this
under things I like frankly because I do
like this I think that when people get
exactly what they deserve it's quite
wonderful so according to media it-- she
got up and she said it's apparently and
they say as one of just four women to
win the sports Person of the Year award
she wasted no time in putting Sports
Illustrated in the hot seat saying in an
acceptance speech is it truth that I'm
only the fourth woman's deserving of
this award I don't think so
is it true so a few writers of color
deserve to be featured in this
publication no is it true so few women's
voices deserve to be heard and deserve
to be read in this publication I don't
think so so she's being given an award
for her social justice activism and she
immediately swivels and clocks the
people giving her the award suggesting
that they are in fact a bunch of sexist
that they haven't given more awards
women in the past so first of all I just
said I think that on a comparative level
she's deserving of the award who else
would be deserving of the award last
year there are few other people maybe
but the fact is and she's as deserving
as anybody in her sphere right if you
are ranking people by their sphere if we
were just gonna go like athlete of the
year like best athlete of the last year
it would never be a woman like literally
ever the reason being the bell curve for
physical performance when you get to the
very edge of the bell curve is all men
because men are built differently than
women but if we are talking about in
their respective sports people who are
important to their particular industry
of course Megan Rapinoe deserves the
award with that said the fact that she
is now dictating to Sports Illustrated
how they got to Staff editorially is
amazing to me and I kind of love it I
kind of love the fact that these Sports
Illustrated sjw woke idiots who are like
Megan Rapinoe we have to give her the
award because you so she hates Trump she
talks about gay marriage
she says that America sucks chill meal
for the oh my god so much harrowing so
much heroism and then she's like well
how about you guys how about you guys
yessss excists yeah brutal vicious
racist white patriarchal sex cysts you
need more women writing for your
magazine
okay gotten an in it I think that she
should be made the editor of Sports
Illustrated Sports Illustrated should
now go all the way they've been called
out by a person Walker than they are and
that means they she should be the
honorary editor they made her the
honorary sports Person of the Year in
part because of her politics why not put
her in charge of your editorial policy
you can fire all of the writers who are
male who are good and you can hire women
whether they are qualified or not and
then you will have achieved some sort of
real parity that'll be great
in November of last year by the way she
won the glamour Woman of the Year award
and then she went after glamour too
Reggie said well I'm enjoying all of
this unprecedented and frankly a little
bit uncomfortable attention okay first
of all the idea that Megan Rapinoe is
uncomfortable with attention if you
believe that I mean really yeah your
head is as empty as it as an airplane
hangar in the middle of the day if you
believe that Megan Rapinoe is
uncomfortable with attention this is a
person who is attention-seeking beyond
all people but she says she's enjoying
all this unprecedented and frankly a
little bit uncomfortable attention and
personal success in large part due to my
activism off the field
Colin Kaepernick is a
to flee band she says I see no clear
example of that system being alive and
well than me standing before you right
now she said this at glamor the fact
that she won an award I'm gonna use this
opportunity to rip on glamour because
you guys didn't do it enough for colin
kaepernick ah here's the thing once you
give the sjw's an inch they will the
alligator will eat you
it may eat you last but the faster you
get in the in the alligators crosshairs
by the way the faster you're in the line
of sight of the SJW alligator the faster
you're gonna get eaten so Sports
Illustrated got the treatment glamour
got the treatment love it love it I only
hope that Megan Rapinoe continues to do
this I hope she continues to wipe the
floor with all of the SJW editors who
worship at her altar and then they come
before her to kiss the ring and she
immediately slaps them she backhands
them across the faces if only you were
more woke if only you were more woke I
think the only the only automatically
under under article 29 of the
Constitution of the United States she
has now become the editor of Sports
Illustrated it's sort of like the it's
sort of like the old code of chivalry
that if you if you had a fight with
somebody someone throw it out throws
it's the Kings justice you throw down
the gauntlet if you have the fight then
you get to take the other person's land
I think it's like that if you invite
Megan Rapinoe to receive an award from
you she receives the award and then she
beats the crap out of you she now
inherits your magazine so she should be
the editor of Sports Illustrated and
glamour she should be the the Ombudsman
of ESPN why the hell not she knows
better than you cuz she plays soccer and
his woke you deserve all of this Sports
Illustrated every little bit of it
already
we'll be back here later today for two
additional hours of content plus we'll
be back here tomorrow it's still the
middle of the week
we'll get there together I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo why douse key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 president Trump is riding high on an
impeachment approval rating bump but the
administration isn't resting on its
laurels from the campaign to the DOJ to
foreign policy Trump is getting more
aggressive in taking on his adversaries
demonstrating an eternal political truth
if you come at the King you best not
miss check it out on the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
you